- So let's get a little bit more comfort
in our understanding of what
a differential equation even is.
So here we have a differential equation.
We haven't started exploring how we find
the solutions for a
differential equations yet.
But let's just say you saw this,
and someone just walked
up to you on the street
and says, "Hey, I will give you a clue,
"that there's a solution to
this differential equation
"that is essentially a linear function,
"where y is equal to mx plus b,
"and you just need to figure out
"the m's and the b's,
or maybe the m and the b
"that makes this linear function
"satisfy this differential equation."
What I now encourage you to do,
is pause the video and
see if you can do it.
So I'm assuming you have paused it,
and had a go at it.
So let's think this through together.
If we know that this kind of a solution
can be described in this way,
we need to figure out
some m's and b's here.
This is telling us that if we were to take
the derivative of this with respect to x,
if we take the derivative of
mx plus b with respect to x,
that that should be equal
to negative 2 times x
plus 3 times y.
well, we know y is this thing, minus 5.
And that should be true for all x's,
in order for this to be a solution
to this differential equation.
Remember, the solution to
a differential equation
is not a value or a set of values.
It is a function or a set of functions.
So in order for this to satisfy
this differential equation,
it needs to be true for
all of these x's here.
So let's work through it.
Let's figure out first what our dy dx is.
So dy dx.
We'll just take the derivative
here with respect to x
dy dx is derivative of
mx with respect to x,
is just going to be m.
And of course derivative
of b with respect to x,
just a constant,
so it's just going to be zero.
So dy dx is m.
So we could write m is
equal to negative 2x,
is equal to negative 2x,
plus 3 times, and instead
of putting y there
I could write mx plus b.
Remember y is equal to mx plus b.
And just as a repeated reminder,
this has to be true for all x's.
mx plus b, and then of
course we have the minus 5.
So if you weren't able to
solve it the first time,
I encourage you to start from here,
and now figure out what
m and b needs to be
in order for this
equation right over here,
in order for this to be true for all x's.
In order for this to be true for all x's.
So assuming you have paused again
and had a go at it, let's just keep
algebraically manipulating this.
I'll just switch to one color here.
So we have m.
m is equal to negative 2x plus,
if we distribute this
3 we're going to have
3mx plus 3b, and then of course
we're going to have minus 5.
And now we can group the x terms.
So if we were to group,
if we were to group ...
Let me find a new color
here, maybe this blue.
So if we were to take these
two and add them together
that's going to be
negative 2 plus 3m times x,
or we could write this
as 3m minus 2 times x,
and then you have your constant terms,
so you have these terms right over here,
so plus 3b minus 5,
and of course that's all
going to be equal to m.
That's going to be equal to m.
Now remember, this needs to be true,
this needs to be true for all x's.
So notice, over here I have
some coefficient times x
on the right-hand side.
But on the left-hand side I have no x's.
So somehow, this thing must disappear.
This is a constant, so
it's completely reasonable.
It's completely reasonable
that this constant
could be equal to m.
But the only way that I
get these x's to disappear
so all I'm left with is an m,
is if this thing is equal to zero.
Let me say that again,
because I think it may be a little bit
counter-intuitive what I'm about to do.
We're saying that m, some constant value,
is equal to some coefficient times x,
plus some other constant value.
Well, in order for a constant value
to be equal to a coefficient times x
plus some other constant value
the coefficient on X
must be equal to zero.
Another way to think about it is,
this should be,
you could rewrite the left-hand side here
as zero x plus m.
So you see, you kind of
match the coefficients.
So zero must be equal to 3m minus 2,
and m is equal to 3b, m
is equal to 3b minus 5.
m is equal to 3b minus 5.
So let's use that
knowledge, that information,
to solve for m and b.
So we could use this first one.
So 3m minus 2 must be equal to zero.
So let's write that.
3m minus 2 is equal to zero,
or 3m is equal to 2,
or m is equal to 2/3.
So we figured out what m is.
Then we could use that information,
because we know that,
we know that m is equal to,
is equal to 3b minus 5.
m is 2/3, so we get 2/3
We could add 5 to both sides,
which is the same thing as
adding 15/3 to both sides.
Is that, did I do that right?
Yeah, adding 5 to both sides
is the same thing as
adding 15/3 to both sides.
So let's do that.
15/3 plus 15/3, these cancel out.
That's just 5 right over there.
On the left-hand side we have
17/3 is equal to 3b,
or if you divide both sides by 3
you get b is equal to 17,
b is equal to 17/9, and we're done.
We just found a particular solution
for this differential equation.
The solution is y is
equal to 2/3x plus 17/9.
And I encourage you,
after watching this video,
to verify that this particular solution
indeed does satisfy this
differential equation
for all x's.
For all x's.